[Musique]
hé la nourriture de la fontaine a l'air vraiment bien trop
bien juste en essayant de
bien se concentrer mon père ne me l'a pas dit juste avant que
je m'y amène parce que je n'étais pas si
évident trop occupé à être obsédé par mes
expériences de rayons gamma J'ai raté mon propre père
la mort parce que je me concentrais sur mon
destin mais je n'ai pas raté la
mort de mon père parce qu'il a été assassiné juste
devant moi par ma sœur dont je ne
savais même pas qu'elle existait parce qu'elle m'était restée
secrète toute ma vie a l'
air terrible  la comparaison n'avait tout simplement
rien à voir avec ce que vous
traversez et ma famille, c'est comme si cela
coûterait de se battre entre nous alors que
tout le monde en souffre non j'étais des
dieux et des chambres et bien c'est
ma sœur hella tu sais si je ne l'ai pas fait  mettre
ton veto car tu pourrais tuer ta sœur a
pensé à comment résumer tu n'es pas
le gars à marteler ici Dumbo ne
ressemble pas à un compliment c'est totalement un
compliment Dumbo Dumbo sonne comme si
tu m'appelais Dumbo encore et
encore
Dumbo  à la maison dis une fois de plus je vais  dis à
ton éléphant que tu penses qu'elle peut voler parce
que c'était une plume magique et puis il
perd sa plume quand Danny réalise qu'il
n'avait rien à voir avec lui
voler du tout désolé
[ __ ] d'homme à plumes d'où je viendrais
était-ce moi tout le temps tu  lui a sorti
la queue
t'as même rien dit on est là
ouais ouais débarrasse toi